it was a decision of potentially
historic proportions to be taken just
two weeks before the start of the rio
games but it was one the IOC bypassed in
deciding to give responsibility to the
28th International Federations choosing
instead to set the guidelines by which
each sport will regulate the entry of
Russian athletes every human being is
entitled to individual trustees there we
have set the bar to the absolute limit
for how Russian athletes can achieve to
compete in real all of them have to meet
individually these number of very strict
criteria under the guidelines set out
today by the IOC no Russian athlete with
the doping sanction will be accepted
even if he or she has already served the
sanction it's under this provision
whistleblower Yuliya Stepanova whose
revelation of widespread state-sponsored
doping were key and bringing the russian
system to light will not be able to
compete indeed the international sports
federations must also carry out an
individual analysis of every other
athletes anti-doping record taking into
account only international tests russian
tests can not be taken into
consideration when you my opinion we are
very aware that the Olympic Committee
has to strike a balance between
collective responsibility and the rights
of the individual athletes and in the
end they settled on a decision that any
athlete with a clean reputation and no
doping record has the right to take part
in the Olympic Games who would know
bizzle brief the International Tennis
Federation was the first to take a
decision in light of the IOC
announcement clearing seven Russian
players to compete in the Olympic
tournament